this is a replica of James Cook's
endeavor which sailed into the northern
city of Gisborne in 1769 nine indigenous
people were killed just in the first
meeting between cook and the Maori who
had been living in New Zealand for
centuries and that is one of the many
reasons why these protesters say the
occasion shouldn't be commemorated since
the landing of white men these been
nothing but distressed
dishonesty killing murderous you name it
we've done it two hundred and fifty
years right in here we still are to this
day protesters also say their Maori
ancestors were treated unfairly during
the colonial era and that today Maori
communities face disproportionate levels
of poverty crime and discrimination as a
result New Zealand has planned several
days of events to mark the milestone
Prime Minister Jacinta Arden says there
should be a more open conversation about
the country's history telling stories to
acknowledge that and to ensure that our
children continue to know those stories
as well once upon a time I used to be
cook cook but now we actually have a
balance of stories of Maori Evie kind
stories and a little bit of cook stories
in Gisborne a statue of James Cook has
been repeatedly defaced with graffiti
and is to be replaced but many here say
there needs to be a bigger dialogue on
the treatment of the Maori people
throughout New Zealand's history dorsa
Jabari al-jazeera